you sing a song that kids will be
singing until the end of time boyfriend
Oh everything is although you have
written one of those songs that children
until the end of time will be screaming
at the top of their lungs all right well
to be totally clear we didn't write it
nope but we sang it did sing it we did
perform it on the Oscars it sort of does
we do sort of feel a responsibility we
get it it'll always be associated always
with you and and we're so hot we were
there we were really honored to be
associated with a film that first of all
this is a great movie I'm just gonna
come right out I have no idea what's
going on we didn't know that when we
signed on we saw like four minutes I
think of a film and we were like that
seems pretty smart yes overpriced coffee
that's $37 awesome that's just one of
those one once in a lifetime things that
just we were in the right place at the
right time these people thought of us
and we had a kind of crazy life
experience because I they do everything
is still awesome or everything is
awesomer oh yeah yes yeah getting to
reach so many people never forget the
moment on stage at the end of the Oscars
looking out at that room of people which
is just packed with every celebrity and
well-known person you've ever seen you
know you're being beamed out to like
tens of millions of people and I just
thought like we're part of history like
this is a moment
now the 35 year old twin sisters are
hoping to create more moments with their
eighth studio album love you to death I
think because we've been around for so
long we felt we had earned the right to
explore our musical background and that
meant getting more into pop music let's
write songs we've really really love and
like let's really challenge ourselves
and here we are the pair will also be
kicking off their world tour later this
month which includes eight stops across
Canada I play music every single day i
mean i wanna i want it to sound better i
want to sing better i wanted to look
better when I'm on stage and I look like
I know what I'm doing I want the
instruments to be into you know like
we've grabbed